NOW IT'S TIME TO PLAY "THUG LIFE
OR HUG LIFE?"
>> IF YOU DON'T KNOW "UNEXPECTED
THUG LIFE"
THEN YOU DON'T KNOW ( BLEEP ).
IT'S A CLASSIC INTERNET MEME
THAT EXPOSED SEEMINGLY INNOCENT
KIDS FOR THE HARD-ASS
MOTHERSUCKERS THEY ARE.
THIS IS WHAT THUG LIFE IS ALL
ABOUT.
>> SAY HELLO TO THE CAMERA.
HELLO MOTHER(BLEEP).
>> I NEVER WANTED TO BE A FATHER
UNTIL RIGHT NOW.
>> CHRIS: COMEDIANS I'M GOING TO
SHOW YOU A STILL OF SOMETHING
ADORABLE AND FOR 250 POINTS, I
WANT YOU TO TELL ME IF THEY'RE
CUTE LITTLE THUGS OR CUTE LITTLE
HUGS.
THE FIRST ONE, THIS GODDAMN
GINGER.
>> I'M GOING TO GO THUG LIFE.
>> CHRIS: LET'S SEE.
>> EXCUSE MY POTTY MOUTH. SHUT
THE (BLEEP) UP.
>> I HAVE TO GIVE RICHIE
CUNNINGHAM CREDIT FOR SAYING,
"EXCUSE MY LANGUAGE.
SHUT THE ( BLEEP ) UP!" HE'S
VERY POLITE.
>> THAT'S MY GINGE.
>> CHRIS: OH MY GOD, THERE'S TWO
OF YA.
>> CHRIS: NEXT ONE.
HOW ABOUT THESE ADORABLE
CHILDREN?
JONAH?
>> HUG LIFE.
>> CHRIS: I THINK YOU MAY BE
SURPRISED.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
>> AS SOON AS HE STARTED
MUTTERING, THE BABY SHOULD HAVE
BEEN TAKEN AWAY.
LIKE ANY WOMAN KNOWS AS SOON AS
A GUY IS MUTTERING ON THE
SUBWAY, YOU SWITCH CARS.
>> I DID NOT EXPECT THAT.
THAT WAS SO ( BLEEP )ED UP.
>> CHRIS: THEY'RE FINE,
PROBABLY.
>> I FEEL BAD FOR THE PARENT
THAT FILMS IT AND JUST GOES,
"THUG LIFE MEME."
>> DON'T WORRY, WE'LL MAKE
ANOTHER ONE.
>> THAT WAS TAKE FOUR.
>> IT WAS A WHOLE BUCKET OF
BABIES THEY WERE GOING THROUGH.
A BUCKET OF BABIES.
NEXT ONE, WHAT ABOUT THIS MATH
WHIZ?
THUG LIFE OR HUG LIFE?
JULIE?
>> I'M GOING TO HOPE HUG LIFE.
>> I LOVE HOW PEOPLE ARE TELLING
ME I'M, LIKE, TWO-NINE YEARS
OLD.
I'M ELEVEN, SO SHUT THE (BLEEP)
UP.
THIS LI'L SELFIE.
THUG LIFE OR HUG LIFE?
>> JONAH?
>> THUG LIFE BECAUSE HE LOOKS
LIKE A YOUNG EMINEM.
>> "HEY KIDS, ARE YOU READY FOR
"MODERN WARFARE 3"? WELL,
YOU'RE NOT OLD ENOUGH TO PLAY
IT, SO GET THE (BLEEP) OFF."
>> HE ALMOST DIDN'T MAKE IT.
HE ALMOST WENT HUG.
>> I THINK THAT'S HUG LIFE.
>> CHRIS: HE WAS ON THE BORDER
OF HUG AND WENT STRAIGHT INTO
THUG.
SHUT THE ( BLEEP ) UP.
WHY ARE YOU WHISPERING SO YOUR
PARENTS WON'T HEAR
WHEN YOU WILL PUT IT ON THE
INTERNET?
THIS ONE MAY SURPRISE YOU.
THUG LIFE OR HUG LIFE?
>> I'LL SAY THUG LIFE BECAUSE
THEY'VE ALL BEEN THUG LIFE.
>> WHAT DID YOU
LEARN IN SCHOOL TODAY?
HE LEARNED NOT TO GO PEE PEE IN
YOUR PANTS, HUH?
YAYY, GOOD JOB!